[Music]
the future of food looks like this it's
a new operation run by a company called
impossible foods that's churning out
something that looks feels tastes and
smells like ground beef hell it even
bleeds like a medium-rare burger but
this patty is actually all plant a
product of genetic engineering it's the
first step in an effort to take on the
multibillion-dollar meat industry you
won't be disappointed me thank you man
it's hard to overstate the magic of a
traditional burger the taste for one but
also the smell and texture that's thanks
to lots of different kinds of proteins
most importantly myoglobin which
contains something called heme that's
the taste of iron you get when you're
cooking a piece of meat what happens is
the protein that's carrying the heme
myoglobin your muscle opens up the heme
comes out and catalyzes a bunch of
reactions that create the volatile
compounds that really give that smell
that flavor that makes meat so
compelling your traditional veggie
burger can't get the taste anywhere near
right because they ain't got that heme
but plants contain globin molecules just
like animals do specifically of interest
to impossible foods is the root of the
soy plant which contains leg hemoglobin
this helps very oxygen around it also
contains that magical heme but the
amount of soy roots these scientists
would need in order to produce enough
heme would be outlandish
in a more efficient approach that we
came up with was to engineer a yeast and
have that produce very high quantities
of that heme when impossible Foods has
invented is a tiny he machine and with
meat free he it has the foundation of a
stunning imitation of a beef burger
so let's find out how they do it this is
where we really try to understand what
makes meat meat test each of the kind of
key parameters impossible is trying to
isolate and then recreate as many meat
like components as they can and this
machine is helping them do it so what I
have in front of you is a gas
chromatograph mass spectrometer what
this does is allows for us to be able to
take a sample so say a beef sample put
it in here we'll move this sample we
have a nice little robot they'll take
that sample and move it into a cooker so
then we could cook this sample at
whatever temperature we want to
understand what flavors are generated
upon cooking so those aromas again is
what creates the flavor of meat so we
will now have kind of a fingerprint of
every single aroma that is in beef and
then we can say how close is the
impossible burger where can we make
improvements and iterate to identify how
to make each of those particular flavor
compounds the other part that's really
important in the burger are all meats is
the textural component what are the
things that are driving texture in meat
those are proteins and we want to
characterize those particular proteins
then as we identify what those
particular proteins properties are we go
and look and plants for plant proteins
that have those same properties and then
behind me I have Michelle who's one of
our scientists who really takes each of
those individual proteins and
characterizes it understands is it
stretchy how much tensile strength does
it have how much water does it hold
and by characterizing each of those
particular proteins we then understand
how it will behave in our particular
burger so it all comes down to these
ingredients which include the heme wheat
protein for texture and coconut as a
stand-in for fat add them all together
and it starts to look more and more like
a beef patty
the result is a meatless burger that's
so convincing it may as well be meat all
right pretty impressive we even asked
our resident chef to give it a taste so
it's really simulating that juicy center
layer that you would get in a nice
mid-rare burger so on you can see on the
outside we've got that nice golden crust
but in the center it's still bloody and
rare except this time it's plant threw
in the bleeding so let's see what how it
tastes okay wow that is a lot better
than I thought it would be Wow so why
does a veggie burger need to bleed
because this isn't targeted to
vegetarians and vegans is designed to
convert meat-eaters okay so it's good
sure but is this engineered food safe
the thing is while humans eat plenty of
soy they don't typically eat the roots
which is where you'd find this leg
hemoglobin so this is a brand new
ingredient in the food supply well the
company isn't required by law to report
its use of a new ingredient to the FDA
it did so voluntarily with soy leg
hemoglobin but the FDA determined that
impossible foods had not yet presented
sufficient evidence for the agency to
recognize it as safe however that is not
to say the FDA determined that leg
hemoglobin is unsafe and impossible
Foods says it's had experts confirmed
the meatless meat is perfectly fine to
consume and found no adverse effects in
a rat feeding study it is structurally
similar to proteins that we consume all
the time but critics say the FDA's
objections weren't further testing of
the impossible burger in the meantime
the company is scaling its production
from 300,000 to 1 million pounds a month
at the end of the day meat production is
flat-out inefficient and as our
population expands we're going to need
more sustainable foods to meet the
demand
so the impossible burger is just the
beginning of a new breed of high-tech
eats and you know what they say if it
bleeds it leads
you